what really struck me it goes to
Cambridge was the people who said I
don't really like Corbin I'm not a
Labour voter I support the Conservatives
but actually they need to do a bit more
of what labour is doing when it comes to
things like rel nationalization or
sharing wealth more equally I mean it
what do you think they're right well I
think the chap at the market spoke
exactly I think we need to be honest and
recognize that some of the things that
Labour are doing are speaking for the
anxieties of the British people a
general sense of unfairness a fact that
many millions of our country men and
women have struggled with the difficult
economic situation so we need to be
honest about that and we need to present
a moral message about conservatism we
need to show that we're on the side of
those who are struggling the most we
need to show that we're on the side of
workers we need to be seen as the social
justice party and it can't just be about
brexit and it can't just be about
economics I mean do you think at the
moment the Conservative Party has a bit
of an image problem I mean you represent
Harlow don't you a kind of blue-collar
conservative st. formerly a labour seat
how do people in Harlow view in the
Conservative Party well I mean they
voted for me but I think we do have a
serious image problem I think that
people don't understand what our values
are they just think we're about one
thing austerity or brexit they think
that the Conservative Party doesn't
speak for people who have real
difficulties in their day-to-day lives
and I think we can turn that around and
the Prime Minister to be fair did go
back to being the Prime Minister 2016 in
her conference speech a couple of weeks
ago talking about the cost of living
fuel duty-free is more council housing
but we need to do a lot more so what do
you want to see you've got a budget
that's an opportunity isn't it what
would you like to in the world we need
to have a workers budget it's got to
focus on the cost of living we should
carry on cutting taxes for low earners
we've got to sort the universal credit
out it needs to be a skills budget so we
should do a lot more we should guarantee
every single young person in our country
an apprenticeship who wants one we need
to be the cost of living a party cutting
the cost of living party so it should be
cutting the cost of living budget we'd
have to do something about extortionate
train fares and utility bills and the
government done some good things that
I've recognised but there is a lot more
we need to do in a bubble we need to
kind of present
narrative not just have a series of
clothes pegs without a washing line it
sounds expensive do you think we need to
borrow a bit more it may be that we need
to borrow more in terms of capital
funding to build more you know build our
infrastructure new hospitals our roads
but actually I think we can manage the
existing budget better so for example
people in micro city of Harlow can't
understand why we're still giving 14
billion pounds in overseas aid when my
Harlow stroke association or ha-lo
stroke group I should say doesn't have
enough mining has to get rid of a
coordinator so she would cut that budget
and use that to help the lower pay if
you say the Conservative Party has an
image problem then that's not really
helping the kind of nasty party image is
it well we'd still give money I'm saying
let's say if we cut it by half from 14
billion 1314 billion to 6 7 billion it's
not that I'm saying give it to the rich
what I'm saying is we should use that
money to help those most in need and I
think the public would understand that
especially at times when there isn't a
lot of money going around I mean we say
for example business taxes we say that
more money comes into the Exchequer by
cutting business taxes and that's
something like it went up by 21 percent
between 26 2017 why don't we set up a
capitalist redistribution fund and give
that money back to a low-paid or spend
on poor communities we were talking a
little bit earlier about labour and you
were saying not to sort of underestimate
the threat of labour if there was an
election tomorrow do you think Jeremy
Corbyn would win well who knows what
would happen I think that in a very I
think that they're in a very powerful
position we're just the latest poll says
it's roughly level pegging over a few
points behead lasts in 2017 we were 20
points ahead and look what happened so
we need to get our message right we need
to possess a could win election I think
that they're in a good position yes if
I'm honest but I think we could be in a
good position to if we can get our
message round if we present ourselves as
the party of the lateral opportunity if
we've seen on the side of workers if
we're seen as the party for social
justice for skills and a genuinely
affordable housing then I think there's
all to play for
now I mean things have got pretty bad
have now if one of your own MPs is
saying that he wouldn't vote
conservative if he wasn't in Westminster
I'm talking of course about that
extraordinary intervention
Johnny Mercer he also said if he wasn't
an MP he wouldn't stand to be one now
for the Conservative Party I mean is
that is that how you feel no I mean I
understand where a lot of these MPs are
coming from and Johnny Mercer who all
that is it is a good is a good person
what I want to happen is for the prime
minister to get back to being the prime
minister was in 2016 when she stood on
the steps of Downing Street and said
that her main priority would be to
address burning social injustice ha's
and captured the mood of the country and
I don't think the change of leader would
particularly help especially in the
middle of brexit and I think she
deserves support in that whether we have
agreements or disagreements about the
approach but I do think she has to be
the Prime Minister of 2016 I mean some
of the comments in the newspaper today
are pretty shocking to be honest some of
the language
Johnny Mercer's not necessarily one of
them but some of the anonymous quotes
about her in the paper the Sunday Times
says she's in the killing zone the mayor
on Sunday she should bring her noose to
the 19:22 committee meeting I mean this
really sounds like she's lost control of
the party well I'd say to those people
who are giving those quotes this is not
the way to change things this just
confirms what many in the public think
of us that we're all out potentially out
for ourselves and not on the side of
working people what we need to do is be
fighting for policies and fighting for
conservative values as I've been talking
about about social justice doesn't I
mean look at Johnny Mercer for example
saying that Theresa May has to go
because he can't continue to support an
administration that cannot function when
you you're making a very pointed
critique of where the party are surely
that is linked him with the leadership
but who is this magic king or queen over
the water that is suddenly going to
solve all the Conservative Party
problems and it doesn't matter if it's
treason May or Mother Teresa unless we
get our values right unless we are seen
by the public that we're on their side
and as we sort out the brexit thing and
actually unify as a party it doesn't
matter whose leader there's there's no
one as I can see who's got some magic
solution is going to solve everything
quite depressing then you can't you look
at the concept adventures and you can't
pick out someone you think actually no
what if that person was leader then I
could really rally behind he might
really speak to Michael's I'm not saying
though on even though a minute there are
many talented people and there are some
great people who may be leader of the
Conservative Party I suspect that the
next leadership contest will be like out
of a Ben Hur movie it'll be a cast of
thousands running for the position of
leader or Prime Minister but what I
think we need to do first is get our
values right and I think what would
solve the problem is the tweezer May and
she's Sigma signaled a little bit of
this at conference but it can't just be
a speech it's got to be something really
serious to be the Prime Minister she
said she was going to be on the steps of
Downing Street in 2016 2016 words only
when we lost that when it was just a
kind of confusion the father brexit that
we started to go down in the opinion
polls and when we lost our way with our
as I call it the Allenby start manifesto
of 2017 and that the public moved away
from the Conservatives I mean one person
that is often talked up as a potential
caretaker leader is David Davis how do
you feel about that well again it's all
speculation David Davis is very talented
he's comes from a working background
that many people would relate to but so
do others you know and so but I go back
to my main points this is no in my view
of magic King or Queen over the water
ready to jump in and everything that
every problem that the country has will
automatically be solved let's get our
values right let's get our messaging
right let's present ourselves our party
is the party the ladder of opportunity
for millions of working people in our
country and then let's see what all
these leadership candidates when the
Prime Minister decides to go but she
just let's see what's their path after
after march after well it may be that
she decides to go after she's got breaks
it through I think that's gonna be a
matter for her but I would it be a good
idea you think to hand over to a new
generation well there's no point in
saying let's have a new generation till
I know what these people are going to
stand for I don't know what whoever is
going to standard in all the platforms I
don't know what they're going to do for
the country I don't know what they know
what their concern what they're going to
do for Conservative Party so I think
it's not the right way to approach it
let's sort out our values our mission
key that ballast and mission you're
chair of the Education Select Committee
what would you like to see when it comes
to education and social mobility because
for many people you know this is the key
- yes values well I mentioned earlier I
think we should guarantee not just say
we're gonna have more apprenticeships
which we're doing but actually we can't
match the corporate promise on tuition
fees would cost billions and billions of
pounds of taxpayers money wouldn't be
fair to people who are not students who
would end up paying for this what we can
do is say to every single person will
guarantee you an apprenticeship if you
want one so you get the skills you earn
while you learn there's no debt you
climb up that ladder of opportunity to
get job security and prosperity at the
top of the ladder that is the sort of
thing we should be offering our young
people we should be addressing social
injustice is so for example we have 40
children excluded every day in our skill
is there a risk though that by kind of
out try to outdo Corbin you're never
gonna win at that game you need to try
and find something that is kind of
uniquely conservative but it's not out
doing korben korben cleverly I don't
think he has the right solutions to this
but they're recognizing the anxieties of
working people across the country we
need to show that we recognize those
anxieties too and come up with
conservative solutions I mentioned one
to you about using the extra monies
raised from business taxes that have
come in from cutting businesses to spend
on poorer communities there are many
things that that conservatives could do
but we have to show working people that
were on their side
if you don't could you lose constituency
like Harlem at some point if we don't
get this right and be the social justice
party be there what party for workers be
the part of our opportunity then yes we
will face say I in my view of potential
huge defeats at the coming election is
it existential for the party well I
think there were a number of existential
questions facing our party our lack of
membership our problem with message our
problem with policies the divisions over
brexit and I'm being very honest about
that to you
so that's why we've got to get these
things right that's why I'm arguing in
the way that I am that be the Prime
Minister you were in 2016 it isn't just
can't just be about brilliant speech as
a party conference it's got to be about
getting this and translating this into
apps
okay what about half and thank you very
much